et ce n'est pas fini arrivé donc ce
matin à orly 10h40 l'avion avait tourné
pendant 15 minutes car il était en
avance
10h40 au pied du tapis rouge au pied de
la passerelle se trouve monsieur jacques
baumel secrétaire d'état auprès du
premier ministre pour accueillir neil
amstrong que vous voyez descendre en
tête en compagnie de sa femme qui porte
un très joli tailleur bleu et rouge
les enfants des écoles et un groupe de
250 petits américains ont accueilli et
les astronautes aussi en poussant des
hurlements de joie vous les voyez là-bas
dans le fond accueillant les trois
hommes michael collins et edwin aldrin
sont là derrière les trois épouses
s'installe dans l'iss bas ce fameux
salon d'honneur d'orly qui va
disparaître d'ailleurs coïncidence juste
après le voyage des astronautes
dès demain alors découvert
j'ai le grand plaisir d'accueillir
aujourd'hui les trois héros de la plus
grande épopée que l'humanité ait connu
je souhaite la bienvenue à ces trois
hommes de la lune que tout à l'heure
paris accueillera et applaudira c'est
monsieur jacques baumel qui recevait les
trois hommes et armstrong répète c à h
personne ne fera de l'ouest avoir
remercié le peuple français de son
accueil
neil amstrong présente ses deux
camarades aylwin irene son équipage
tribune son équipage et nous nous
retrouvons maintenant à l'hôtel de ville
il est 12h15 dans une voiture de
l'ambassade
les trois hommes arrivent place de
l'hôtel de ville accueilli par des
dizaines de milliers de personnes et par
monsieur etienne de very pour le
président du conseil de paris encadrés
par les deux préfet de paris et de
police messieurs diébold et grimaud les
enfants des écoles ont été conviés à
cette manifestation il y à de nombreux
jeunes américains 1927
sur cette même place les parisiens à
clan mais dans l'enthousiasmé charles
lindbergh et aujourd'hui voici que les
parisiens sont venus en foule comme à
londres pour celui/celle heureusement
d'autres fils de l'amérique à billes
vous gernez a besoin ses premiers pas
sur la lune ont sans doute marqué le
commencement d'une ère nouvelle pour
notre espèce comme lorsque christophe
colomb que je crois vous avez salué en
espagne élargissant les bandes de
l'ancien monde découvrait ce nouveau
monde aux abymes et après ce discours
d'accueil monsieur etienne devait ricour
le président du conseil au pari
remettait aux trois astronautes la
médaille de vermeil de la ville de paris
insigne honneur puisque jusqu'à présent
astronautes et cosmonautes en visite à
paris n'avait reçu que la médaille
d'argent
puis il signait un parchemin commémorant
leur visite par le brise glace
de son voyage neil amstrong disait ce
n'était pas l' aventure d'un homme et
laventure de toute l'humanité que ce
premier pas sur la lune voici le
document qui l'ont signé il posé ensuite
longuement pour les photographes en
compagnie de leurs trois épouses les
bras chargés de fleurs puis prenez place
dans une voiture découverte qu'ils
allaient descendre la rue de rivoli pour
rejoindre ensuite l'hôtel matignon où
les attendait le premier ministre
monsieur chaban delmas
il faisait un soleil merveilleux sur
l'hôtel de ville sur la place de l'hôtel
de ville et un léger brouillard de
chaleur estompé un peu les couleurs
voici cette descente de la rue de rivoli
des dizaines de milliers de parisiens
s'étaient massés le long de la rue le
long de tous les kinés rers et
applaudissez frénétiquement l'équipage
d'apollo 11
fraser l'hôtel matignon c'est monsieur
chaban delmas qui était parti plus tôt
du conseil des ministres pour accueillir
les trois hommes qui les accueillit
effectivement sur le perron de l'hôtel
matignon
il saluait neil amstrong d'un salut
champion qui a fait plaisir à nil puis
les accueillait dans le grand salon de
l'hôtel matignon où il devait elle est
décorée leur remettre la croix de
chevalier de la légion d'honneur
jamais monsieur armstrong jamais ce
premier pas et avant le premier pas
votre bras votre main tenant l'échelle
de l'escalier et cette hésitation si
compréhensible que vous avez eue et que
tous nous avons eu avec et aussi ce
sentiment d'arrachement lorsque ce bras
cette main s'était attaché de l'échelle
ainsi c'est pas la jeunesse que vous
avez ouvert les chemins nouveaux et ses
chemins là ce sera à elle maintenant de
s'y engager
au nom du président de la république et
en vertu des pouvoirs qui nous sont
conférés nous vous faisons chevalier de
la légion d'honneur
owen au nom du président de la
république et en vertu des pouvoirs qui
nous sont conférés nous vous faisons
chevalier de la légion d'honneur
au nom du président de la république en
vertu des pouvoirs qui nous sont
conférés nous vous faisons chevalier de
la légion d'honneur
nous avons apprécié votre accueil mais
par dessus tout c'est tonnerre écrasé
semaine non parce que la france ait
connu dans l'histoire et les français
sont connus comme les oreilles ouvrage
courage de l'esprit et courage du coeur
puis c'était le repas et à l'issue de ce
repas réception dans les jardins
photo sur le perron côté jardin de
l'hôtel matignon
un beau un grand nombre de personnalités
tels à présent vous voyez ici jacqueline
auriol derrière andré turcat le premier
pilote de concorde directeur de l'ece
envol et bien sûr le supplice des
autographes ici pour edwin aldrin ceux
qui ne l'empêchent pas de fumer
tranquillement sa pipe
cette réception devait durer jusqu'à
14h45 puis les trois hommes et leurs
épouses devaient passer à l'hôtel
crillon le temps de se changer pour se
rendre à l'élise gestes affectueux du
président chez man delmas à l'égard des
douanes aldrin pour la plus grande joie
des photographes comme vous le voyez
15h15 l'elysée réception officielle par
le président de la république monsieur
georges pompidou de l'équipage d'apollo
11 réceptions très rapide tout au moins
pour nous les journalistes massés dans
le salon des ambassadeurs
où le président devait accueillir les
trois hommes en compagnie de
l'ambassadeur des états unis monsieur
sarr georges treiber et à l'issue de
cette réception officielle les recevoir
ensuite dans son bureau pendant près de
40 minutes
voici l'entrée de l'équipage d'apollo 11
dans le salon des ambassadeurs
après cette offre est présentée et
l'équipage et les trois épouses
monsieur georges pompidou devait poser
en compagnie des trois hommes pour les
photographes et dire notamment je
regrette de ne pas avoir été sur la lune
avec vous ça aurait été une meilleure
photo mais hélas je suis trop vieux
voilà madame vous nous faites
seuls les trois hommes ont été reçus par
le président leurs trois épouses sont
restés en compagnie de madame punisher
iver dans les salons de l'elysée
attendant la fin de cette réception
voici la photo finale les trois hommes
portent leur décoration de chevalier de
la légion d'honneur et c'était la sortie
nous avons pu rapidement posé une
question à mille enfants et légendes et
qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur pour vous
un voyage autour de la lune ou un voyage
autour de la terre et lille en france on
est sorti très bien en disant un voyage
à paris
et là je n'ai pas eu le temps de voir
mais je reviendrai a ajouté neil
visiblement fatigué par toutes ces
épreuves mais il se considère comme un
ambassadeur à la fois de l'espace et des
états unis et remplit très bien son rôle
en compagnie de son équipage et de leurs
épouses et à 16 heures c'était la sortie
de l'elysée après cette courte
déclaration et dans le faubourg
saint-honoré des milliers de personnes
s'étaient massées pour à nouveau
applaudir l'équipage d'apollo 11 vous
allez en juger par les quelques images
qui ce fait